Democrats blame President Trump for a
pandemic that hasn't happened yet
Biden aims for a South Carolina come
back and Bernie's record just keeps
getting worse I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show today's show is
sponsored by expressvpn stands up for
your digital rights take action at
expressive VPN calm / bent
well coronavirus is on the tip of
everybody's tongue I don't mean
literally because then a lot of us would
be dead but coronavirus is obviously in
the news and it should be in the news
it's it's very scary stuff the reason
it's very scary stuff is because no one
knows anything and so when you hear
folks in the media talking as though
they know something is though either
they know that this is not going to
become a major issue or they know that
it is going to become a major issue
understand no one knows anything at this
point and one of the reasons nobody
knows anything at this point is because
China has been actively quashing the
information coming out of China about
the extent of the corona virus how many
people have been infected
how transmissible it is how deadly it is
there are two rates that you really want
to know about when you are talking about
a virus the first rate is the
transmissibility right how high is the
transmissibility is it transmissible via
bodily fluids like ebola for example or
is it transmissible via air if it is
transmissible via air how hard is it to
acquire the virus this virus appears to
have a very high rate of transmission
meaning it appears to be very easily
transmissible this is why you saw that
situation with the cruise ship the South
Korean cruise ship or the Japanese
cruise ship in which the the cruise ship
that I'm in princess ship was
quarantined for like two weeks and
suddenly everybody on board had this
virus it is very easily transmissible
the problem is we don't actually know
the death rates because we don't
actually have good statistics from China
as to how many people have acquired this
virus and how many people have died from
this virus so latest statistics suggest
about 80,000 people in China have
acquired the virus and about 3,000
people in China have died from the virus
that is a significant death rate that's
a very high death rate compared to for
example the flu so the flu has a has a
death rate a mortality rate of about
0.1% maybe a little bit less than 0.1%
this virus has a has a death rate in at
least according to the Chinese model
that is well in excess of two percent it
may be approaching as high as three
percent now we don't have full
information as to which sectors of the
population this most affects is it
affecting young healthy people is it
affecting
they're people I'm gonna give you the
information that we have to start
because I think that we ought to start
with the information that we do have
before we start all the speculation
because everyone in terms of politics in
the economy is politicizing this thing
you have people on the Democratic side
of the aisle are already claiming that
President Trump is responsible for the
spread of coronavirus despite the fact
that we are still in double digits as
far as the number of Americans we know
who have acquired coronavirus and then
you have President Trump out there
suggesting that this thing is all a
media creation that there's no reason to
worry about coronavirus at all you got
the stock market which has plummeted 10%
since its open on Monday the stock
market close to an all-time high on
Friday at close to 29,000 and it is all
the way down at about 26,000 as of this
morning so that obviously is is driven
by lack of information rather than
plethora of information right if there
are more information we'd know whether
this thing is a buy market or a sell
market right if we knew that this thing
we're gonna cool off and it was gonna
die out people would be buying stocks or
maybe great time to buy stocks if
however this thing is gonna get worse
and the supply chains are gonna be
disrupted then that sell-off continues
and a market readjustment occurs that
really is significant okay so here is
what we know the best article I've seen
on this comes from Quinton Ferrell over
at Market Watch talking about a study
from JAMA which is a medical journal the
Journal of American medicine they
released a paper analyzing whatever data
was available from the Chinese it Center
for Disease Control and Prevention now
again the big problem here is that China
was literally imprisoning people who are
talking about this thing early on it
turns out that authoritarian regimes
have a horrible record of stopping
pandemics specifically because they are
more worried about the image of the
regime than they are about stopping the
pandemic so they will take low-level
officials who are trying to raise this
thing up the chain and they will punish
them they try to take people who are
disseminating information to the public
outside of China and they will throw
them in jail
I mean all of that is not a good move
when you are trying to shut down a
pandemic and keep people informed
because people are flying in and out of
China every single day while the Chinese
government is more focused on its image
making publicly and it's an image making
internally than it is on the health of
its own population or the health of the
world that will get to more of what
exactly the statistics show at least the
statistics that we have available again
there's a lack of information to anybody
who tells you differently
anybody who's engaging in sort of
irresponsible speculation about where
the
thing is going without giving you the
facts first is doing you at a service
you should be taking whatever
precautions are necessary what I mean by
that is not that you should be
barricading yourself in your home but it
does mean that like any other emergency
you probably should have a two-week
supply of food and water this is what
the CDC recommends they recommend this
if he I've got tornadoes or earthquakes
that really should not change things
dramatically we're not yet at the point
where where we are talking about
full-scale school shutdowns but we've
seen other countries that are engaging
in that sort of thing so there's a lack
of information it's making people feel
very unsettled and it is too early
frankly to tell people whether they
ought to be feeling unsettled or not
because we just don't know and we just
don't know it's one of the scariest
things in the English language really is
because what you look to from the
government is sort of the protection
that you would get from God if you
prayed right there that government is
going to come in and solve all your
problems government can't even solve all
your problems where you have an
authoritarian government in China the
the notion that government is going to
be able to preemptively tell you that
everything is going to be fine in an
area of great uncertainty is obviously
not true so being realistic about what
government can tell you government can
do things but being realistic about what
government is capable of telling you in
an area of great information at the very
least that I think is the responsible
thing to do so I'll bring you some more
information on this thing in just one
second first let's talk about the window
coverings in your home so you're looking
at all the windows in your home and
you're realizing wait a second some of
these don't even have curtains on them I
mean that's kind of weird and bare
looking why not just get a really nice
set of blinds making your home more
beautiful is easy and affordable with
blinds.com I've been using blinds calm
myself it makes my home look so much
better it makes it look warmer and and
frankly it's nobody's business what goes
on inside my home so I like the idea of
having blinds I my windows
whether you want them to handle
everything with their new measure and
install services or you want to do it
yourself you'll enjoy the blinds calm
treatment it really is fantastic
soup-to-nuts
you get cellular shades wood blinds
plantation shutters pretty much any
known window treatment on the planet at
blinds comm every order gets free
samples free shipping and it's truly
free to talk to a professional designer
blinds.com has no hidden fees or
misleading quotes unlike some other
places plus then 100% satisfaction
guarantee means if you aren't totally
satisfied with the style color or
quality of your window treatments blinds
comm will remake them for free so when
you screw it up they remake it for you
for free you really should go check out
blinds comm right now it makes the
window covering business supremely easy
and affordable
again they will fix everything for you
so really is not up to you and your
magical expertise at blinds making
blinds.com make sure everything looks
great go-to blinds calm the best quality
window treatments at low prices and for
a limited time my listeners save 15% or
more plus an extra 20 bucks off great
great deal with promo code Ben that's
fifteen percent or more on the best
looking blinds shades shutters plus an
extra twenty bucks off at blinds come
with promo code Ben that's blinds comm
promo code Ben rules and restrictions do
apply okay so back to this study from
the medical journal JAMA so they are
basing this on statistics released by
China as of February 11th again this is
incomplete China particularly is gonna
have a stake in claiming that it really
is only claiming old people because it
makes them look really bad if young
people are dying from the virus the
samples over our overall case fatality
rate was 2.3 percent which is
approximately 230 times higher than the
flu is death rate I mean that is it that
is a very very high death rate again the
flus death rate in the United States
last year was about 0.1% if you multiply
that by if you multiply that by 10
sorry it's about 23 times higher my
dad's it's not 230 times about to about
23 times higher by the by these
statistics that I've seen no deaths
occurred in those aged nine or younger
which makes me a little suspicious of
these statistics but cases in those aged
70 to 79 an 8% fatality rate for people
aged 80 years or older fatality rate of
14 point 8 percent no deaths reported
among mild and severe cases but if you
have a secondary condition that
exacerbates it then you got a real
problem on your hands if you have
diabetes or cardiovascular disease or
chronic respiratory disease or
hypertension then this exacerbates
whatever underlying condition you have
and you're likely to have a higher
mortality rate in the latest China based
study not peer-reviewed by US scientists
of course cuz China will not let anyone
in China is a bad actor on the world
stage man they're a bad actor on the
world stage and it's causing a lot of
people to rethink investments in China
now and in the future it found that men
had a fatality rate of 2.8% versus 1.7
percent for women probably a large part
of that is due to the fact that men in
China smoked at a much higher rate than
women apparently about 50% of men in
China smoked and so if you have an
underlying lung condition you have
emphysema or something then it is more
likely that you're gonna die from
exacerbation of that condition via
coronavirus
according to this Jemma study there are
about 82,000 cases confirmed cases of
kovat 19 that's what it's called in at
least 2768 deaths as of Wednesday that
is according to the Johns Hopkins
whiting School of Engineering sensors
for system science and engineering
they're more than 440 cases in northern
Italy so this has indeed become a
pandemic because it is well outside of
China on Thursday China's National
Health Commission said there were 433
new confirmed cases of corona virus in
29 more deaths as of Wednesday bringing
the total number of cases in that
country near 80 thousand the total
number of deaths near 3,000 South Korea
has also reported 334 new cases that
means that there are more than 1500
cases in South Korea Denmark and Estonia
have confirmed their first cases of the
corona virus Brazil confirmed its first
case of corona virus late on Wednesday
and of course in the United States there
about 80 people who have been locked
down in various areas of the United
States the first the first case of an
American who has corona virus from an
untraceable source emerged in northern
california what that means that
everybody else we've been able to trace
to some sort of flight out of China or
contact with somebody else who had
corona virus the fact that we're now
seeing cases that are cropping up in
which people are getting it from we
don't know where that's obviously very
scary one of the big problems with
corona virus as opposed to for example
Ebola is that Ebola is only
transmissible once the symptoms head so
once you start vomiting blood that's
when you are transmissible corona virus
apparently has up to a two-week latency
period where you are exhibiting no
symptoms and yet you're hanging around
people and you're sneezing on them and
you're shaking hands with them and you
can transmit the virus that means that
this thing does have a very very high
transmissibility right
naturally stalks are continuing to
tumble the virus has spread to some 4700
countries and has put pressure on
business and supply chains around the
world according to the New York Times
stock on stocks on Wall Street fell
sharply in early trading on Thursday as
the sixth straight day of losses for the
S&P 500 as investors continued it to
react with fear to the spreading of
corona virus outbreaks the selling could
push major benchmarks and seen that into
the United States into a correction
which would indicate that an index is
down more than 10 percent from its most
recent high we have pushed into that
territory again it is very unclear at
this point how far the coronavirus
crisis is going to go analysts at
Goldman Sachs predicted that companies
in the S&P 500 would generate no profit
growth as a result of the crisis because
of a severe
Klein in Chinese economic activity
disruption in the supply chain for
American companies and a slowdown in the
United States economy again this is not
a specifically American problem in fact
America is getting hit by coronavirus at
a rate far lesser than virtually every
other country but it is a problem pretty
much everywhere else we have seen
coronavirus crop up in dozens and dozens
of countries in Iran it's hitting like
every major person in the government
which is pretty incredible according to
an Iranian official this is Joyce kerim
who is a who's a reporter she is
reporting on on the situation she's in
Washington correspondent for the
National at UAE she she is reporting for
Iranian officials testing positive for
coronavirus including the vice president
for women and Family Affairs one
lawmaker the deputy health minister and
another lawmaker one Iranian official
says there have been 254 cases of known
corona virus in Iran and 26 deaths which
would put their death rate at about 10
percent they've actually canceled Friday
prayers in Iran which is a big deal in
Iran obviously very religiously oriented
country also over in Japan you have seen
the government of japan ordering a
closed to all schools in japan for like
a month
Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a was asking
all elementary middle and high schools
to remain shut until spring holidays
begin in late March this according to
the UK Metro the measure affects twelve
point eight million students at 35,000
schools nationwide according to the
Education Ministry obey said the coming
week or two is an extremely important
time this is to prioritize the health
and safety of the children and take
precautions to avoid the risk of
possible large-scale infections for many
children and teachers who gather and
spend hours together every day Japan now
has more than 890 cases so much more
severe than the United States including
705 from that quarantined cruise ship an
eighth death from the virus was
confirmed Thursday in Japan's
northernmost island of Hokkaido now
considered to be the site of a growing
cluster there have been a bunch of local
governments who had already announced
their decisions to suspend classes we've
already seen outbreaks in northern Italy
Israel has shut down travel to Asia
because there are a lot of Asian flights
that go in and out of Israel Israel shut
down travel out of there there's a lot
of worries about permeability of borders
in the Middle East that if Iran is is
sending people across the border to a
rock you could see outbreaks in Iraq you
see outbreaks in Syria so the problem
with pandemics is obviously pandemics
grow
in a couple of very specific situations
well in general situations - but but
there is specific conditions one
transmissibility of borders permeability
of borders people moving freely enlarge
in large groups of people that is going
to spread this thing much more quickly
and so there's been a lot of talk about
immigration and how this is really
shutting down a lot of Europe - open
immigration policies and - the health
conditions and informational conditions
in a country make a big deal
make a big difference if you don't have
great health facilities if you are
understaffed then the possibility of
this thing really running rampant
through a population is very high if you
can't quarantine people if your medical
workers for example don't have masks
this has been a huge problem in China
they don't have the proper masks they
don't have the proper gear if you don't
have the proper masks and the proper
gear the first line of defense is your
medical personnel and if your medical
personnel are obtaining this stuff and
then dealing with a bunch of other
people or coming in for check-ups then
the transmissibility rate is going to go
up wildly so how well you deal with this
depends on the resources that are
available and yes your capacity to shut
down the movement of human beings in
largely permeable areas and in the
Middle East that's a huge problem
because these borders are largely wide
open in the United States Nassau health
officials are warning residents to
remain vigilance is over 80 people
remain under voluntary quarantine for
possible coronavirus exposure the
county's Department of Health
Commissioner dr. Lawrence Eisenstein
this is according to WCBS 880 says 175
residents have had some sort of
voluntary isolation from the public
family and friends after traveling to
China though there have not been any
confirmed cases in the county or the
rest of New York there are 83 people
still under isolation they have to
remain under quarantine for 14 days to
prevent the possible spread of
coronavirus should they be infected
because again we may not even be able to
detect if somebody has corona virus
until they become symptomatic and they
can still pass that thing along so
people are now being put in quarantine
for a couple of weeks at a time
meanwhile in Germany Germany is warning
over the virus epidemic Germany's Health
Minister said Wednesday the country was
at the beginning of an epidemic as
authorities in the West tested dozens of
people who had contact with a couple
infected with the corona virus gaining a
foothold in Europe Germany has been
bracing for an increase in confirmed
cases because of the number of infected
people spiking in nearby Italy again
that permeability of borders in the EU
not serving well the people of various
countries in in Europe will get some
more of this in just one second first
let's talk
about something incredibly dark since we
are talking about all of us how about
life insurance how about that okay so
now might be a great time to get some
life insurance now listen you're not
gonna die of coronavirus okay I really
don't think you are I don't think I am I
think that truth of truth of truth
whenever there is a situation like this
the sort of alarm overwhelms the alarm
system which is you know part of your
making a lot part of your brain that's
sounding the alarm it tends to overwhelm
our prefrontal cortex the part of our
brain that says let's exercise some
reason there have been three thousand
people dead worldwide in a globe of
seven billion people with that said you
don't know what the future is gonna hold
and this is why you should insure
against it and this is why you should go
check out policy genius.com right now no
one's good at predicting the future and
this is why you have actuaries to do it
for you policy genius makes finding the
right life insurance a breeze in minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers and find your best price you
could save 1,500 bucks or more a year by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies life insurance is
really important but why should you do
it word of mouth you should instead it
shop around and find the best price and
you can do it quickly and easily and not
have to think about it anymore by
heading over to policy genius com policy
genius will handle all the paperwork and
the red tape and policy genius doesn't
just make life insurance easy it can
also help you find the right home and
auto insurance disability insurance so
if your if your perusal of the news
makes you worried at all maybe you can
alleviate some of that worry by going
and getting some life insurance make
sure your family's taken care of in case
god forbid the work should happen go
check how policy genius.com again that's
policy genius.com everybody gets the
future wrong better get life insurance
right policy genius.com so as I say The
Associated Press reporting that Germany
has been bracing for an increase in
confirmed cases because Italy has been
hit with a wave of cases testing in
western Germany came after a 47 year old
man with the virus was hospitalized in
serious condition in Dusseldorf the
man's wife works in a kindergarten which
is great she was confirmed to have
contracted the virus as well a soldier
in the German Air Force who had contact
with the hospitalized man has also
tested positive as well that means there
are 21 total cases in Germany meanwhile
the President of the United States is
finally is is finally speaking out about
all of this and and this is where things
get quite political quite quickly we
will get to President Trump in just one
second one piece of good news this is
good news and bad news the more cases of
coronavirus that are reported and the
few
cases of death that I reported the lower
the death rate is which is good I mean
you want a low death right it means the
your chances of dying are presumably
lower hey at the same time it makes it
very difficult to contain because the
more mild cases there are the more this
thing is being transmitted this is being
report by Vivian Wang for the New York
Times in Hong Kong as a dangerous new
coronavirus has ravaged China and spread
throughout the rest of the world the
outbreak stole his own fear and anxiety
nearly 3,000 deaths more than 81
thousand cases six continents infected
but government officials and medical
experts in there warns about the
epidemic have sounded a note of
reassurance though the virus can be
deadly the vast majority of those
infected so far have only mild symptoms
and make full recoveries it is an
important factor to understand medical
experts said both to avoid unnecessary
global panic and it got a clear picture
of the likelihood of a transmission many
people are now panicking some actually
are exaggerating the risks and dr. Jin
dong-hyun a virality of Hong Kong for
governments for public health
professionals they also have to deal
with these because these will also be
harmful again it is important to
remember that even if the death rate is
2.3 percent right that sounds really
scary it means 2 out of every 100 people
die but this is a brain trick to a
certain extent ok number one your
chances of obtaining corn virus are not
a hundred percent - even if you do have
corona virus there's a 98 out of 100
chance that you will not die from it
hey which sounds a lot better than two
out of a hundred that you will die it's
it's it's a weird way that the human
brain works is that if you say to
somebody your chances of death are 2 and
100 you're like oh bleep if you say it
honestly 49 out of 50 people who obtain
this do not die 98 out of 100 people who
obtain this do not die and the chances
that your do obtain it are fairly low
and then it kind of lowers that the
rates of panic with that said again
because there are so many mild cases
that means that it is hard to determine
how far and how fast this thing is going
to is going to move apparently the
overall fatality rate in China is 2.3
percent but the number is inflated by
the much higher fatality rate in Hubei
province which is 2.9 percent the rest
of the country it's 0.4 percent so
that's a lot more that makes you a lot
more sanguine right I mean the fact is
that who Bay which is where this things
started and before the government really
started to crack down and happens to be
one of the more impoverished areas of
China right that's why they're eating
food from wild animal markets right that
that area has a two point nine percent
death right but 0.4 percent death rate
means that 99
point six percent of people who obtain
the virus do not die from it 996 people
yes 996 people out of a thousand will
not die from the virus so that is
somewhat I mean it's a little bit more
it's a little bit more I would say
calming with that said we still don't
know what would mean if the corona virus
outbreak hit the United States what
exactly people would do in schools would
they would they shut down the schools
presumably presumably a lot of people
would be sent home and and here we get
into the Trump administration response
so the Trump administration response is
the same as every other government
response which is we're doing the best
we can and now one of the things that
you don't want from the government is
you don't want mixed messages you don't
want them downplaying the risk to the
point where it seems like they're not
taking it seriously and you also don't
want the President of the United States
just going out there and shooting
off-the-cuff right this is an area where
message discipline really does matter
and the fact that President Trump has
this habit of going on Twitter and
firing off missives on the topic is
really dumb now as we will see the
Democrats are trying to blame from for
pandemic that number one has nothing to
do with Trump and number two Trump
hasn't bashed yet so it's very it's
they're obviously trying to take
advantage of this but two things can be
true at once it can be true that Trump's
handling of public relations is very
haphazard and that president from tends
to speak again like a talk radio caller
and that puts him in that that makes
people uneasy and the president over the
last week since this has started to
explode in the news the president's over
the last week tweeted out that the media
were making the most of coronavirus c AR
o spelling it wrong and then he
suggested that a vaccine was going to be
developed within the month
that is not true his people then came
forth and said he was talking about
Ebola vaccine which is super useless
great apparently is gonna take 12 to 18
months according to the CDC to develop
some sort of really effective vaccine
against coronavirus as the president was
putting out information that wasn't
exactly true I've been saying for weeks
at this point since the corona virus
thing started let your experts talk
mister president sit down and don't do
this and don't be the guy who has to
mouth off on all of this stuff
dr. Nancy Missoni A's director of the
National Center for immunization and
respiratory diseases at the CDC she said
she had contacted her own local school
superintendent this week asked if the
district was prepared she advises
parents
the same she suggested that perhaps
internet-based Telus : could replace
traditional schools not clear exactly
how that is going to work with that said
the government should be taking the
stuff incredibly seriously and
downplaying the sort of risks of this
thing that would be a rather large
mistake so president Trump held a press
conference yesterday and he explained
that Americans should be feeling pretty
good about this thing he said we made
Americans much safer early on which is
honestly it's hard to take super
seriously when you're seeing the first
cases in the United States of community
infection crop up community an infection
meeting somebody got infected we don't
know from where here's President Trump
yesterday saying we made Americans safer
early on we have through some very good
early decisions decisions that were
actually ridiculed at the beginning we
closed up our borders two flights coming
in from certain areas areas that were
hit by the coronavirus and hit pretty
hard and we did it very early a lot of
people thought we shouldn't have done it
that early and we did and it turned out
to be a very good thing and the
number-one priority from our standpoint
is the health and safety of the American
people and that's the way I viewed it
when I made that decision
that's good Trump okay that's good Trump
because the fact is that what you do
need from the presidents at this point
is him saying yeah we put up the walls
yes I mean that the borders closed but
we're not we're not importing this
disease from all areas of the globe so
that's good Trump bad Trump is where the
president then dismisses warnings from
the CDC
the CDC basically said that there will
be an outbreak here it's inevitable and
from said it's not inevitable I I
disagree with my own CDC head okay well
honestly I don't think that the
president is an expert in virology I
don't think the president is an expert
in medicine I don't think that the
president is an expert in in anything
medically related I mean this is a guy
who in 2012 was tweeting out that
vaccines cause autism so I really am NOT
taking seriously his his battle with the
CDC it's hard to credit that again let
your people talk let your people talk
and don't downplay the rich Lowry who's
certainly an allied the president over
at the National Review he was pointing
out a Politico that the president should
be pointing out that this is like a
thing that people should be taking
seriously Americans are taking this
seriously when you downplay people's
fears in the United States it doesn't
make them feel any better it's like when
you are
having a fight with your spouse and you
say to them calm down have they ever has
anyone ever gotten calm when told to
calm down there's not a single person on
planet earth who has gotten calmer when
told to calm down the only way that
people feel calmer is when you take
their fear seriously and you say okay I
totally understand the fear here's what
we're doing to mitigate it I think that
a lot of that fear is reasonable here's
what is probably unreasonable right that
is that's the way to handle this thing
going out there and battling with your
own CDC and saying it's not inevitable
that like that's not useful here was so
good Trump was we made Americans safer
early on we shut down a lot of travel
here is bad from dismissing his own
CDC's warning I don't think it's
inevitable I probably will it possibly
will it could be at a very small level
or could be at a larger level what
whatever happens we're totally prepared
we have the best people in the world you
see that from the study we have the best
prepared people the best people in the
world Congress is willing to give us
much more than we're even asking for
it's nice for a change but we are
totally ready willing and able
they say he said that the risk to the
American people remains very low and
then he said we're ready to adapt
they're ready to do whatever we have to
do if the disease spreads if it spreads
we'll spend whatever is appropriate
right that's the part again the good
trump is we're gonna do we have to do
right good Trump is we did what we had
to do by shutting down the borders we're
gonna do what we have to do going
forward whatever happens we're prepared
for it right that's that's good
reassuring Trump bad Trump is I'm gonna
argue with the assessment of my own
scientific community about the
quote-unquote inevitability of some sort
of outbreak in the United States dr. Ann
shook at is the principal deputy
director of the CDC she said our
aggressive containment strategy here in
the United States has been working and
is responsible for the low level of
cases we have so far however we do
expect more cases the trajectory of what
we're looking at over the weeks and
months ahead is very uncertain okay
which again is the responsible thing to
do okay so I do not think that the
president is wildly mishandling this or
anything I think that the president is
handling this about is pretty much what
the president should do right we shut
down the border we're gonna do whatever
we have to do to shut this down we're
gonna make resources available and all
of the rest and frankly I don't think
that the president is unjustified in
blasting Nancy Pelosi in the rest of the
Democrats as we will see momentarily the
Democrats have been jumping on this to
claim that President Trump is
responsible for the spread of
coronavirus which is just insane
it's just a crazy contention now does
the president have a big mouth when he
says things like I doubt my own CDC I
don't know if it's never like yes that's
a big mouth stuff it doesn't make the
American people feel better with that
said has the president done anything to
merit the kind of insane media coverage
that is blaming him for a pandemic that
has not yet happened of course not and
it shows that the media are covering
this thing in the same way they've
covered everything during the Trump
administration they're preemptively
blaming they're preemptively shaming
without the evidence actually being
there a Nancy Pelosi is out there
blaming Trump for a pandemic that has
not yet occurred suggesting that that he
has that he has botched the response
already how's he explain explain how you
botched the response so Trump yesterday
blasted Pelosi said she's incompetent
and she's trying to use this to score
political points again both of those
things are true I think speaker Pelosi
is incompetent
she lost the Congress once I think she's
gonna lose it again she lifted my poll
numbers up ten points I never thought
that I would see that so quickly and so
easily I'm leading everybody we're doing
great I don't want to do it that way
it's almost unfair if you think about it
but I think she's incompetent and I
think she's not thinking about the
country she knows it's not true she
knows it's all all they're trying to do
is get a political advantage
this isn't about political advantage
we're all trying to do the right thing
okay this right here is absolutely from
and when Trump goes after the Democrats
for what they are saying on this sort of
stuff that is a hundred percent true I'm
gonna show you an example of the New
York Times literally blaming the entire
virus on Trump I mean it's insane I'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about watches so I am a watch
fanatic I don't know if you've heard me
talk about this before I love everything
from luxury watches to fashion watches
I'm just I'm big into watches and
great-looking watches are my thing like
I wake up every morning I'm excited to
put on my watches one of the watches
that I am excited to put on is venture
watch check this thing out this is
really pretty right I mean this thing
does not cost a fortune it is really
quite beautiful Fincher offers free
shipping 30-day returns and guarantees
at your watch for two years when you put
it on you immediately know you got more
than you paid for there are certain
watches where you are paying way too
much for the product pinch arrow is not
one of those watches it's terrific value
for your money
which is why Vin Sheryl has over 20,000
five-star reviews on their site which
you can read for yourself I've been
Sheryl watches calm slash Schapiro
because Vin Sheryl watches our
I've gotten one for my dad I got one for
my brother-in-law I got one for my
sister for her birthday and actually for
my other sister for her birthday I got
one for my wife like they're really
beautiful he's been Cheryl watching
they're not gonna cost you a fortune and
they're really good-looking right they
look like a much more expensive watch
bin Cheryl will always help you stand
out and they're doing it with watches
under 200 bucks so it doesn't cost you a
fortune to give a really nice birthday
gift if you're paying more than that for
a timepiece then you are probably
overpaying check this thing out right
here right it's pretty then Cheryl has
styles for men and women again my wife
has a couple of watches from them as
well as an array of accessories all made
with the same incredible quality as
their watches this deal really is too
good to pass up do me a favor go to VI n
CER o then Cheryl watches comm /a
Pierrot use my discount code Shapiro for
a discount at checkout do not pay full
price on these beautiful timepieces when
you can just go to the intercom and use
my promo code Shapiro at checkout use
that code Shapiro at checkout it really
is fantastic by the way you can also
engrave the back of the watch which is
pretty clean if you get a slogan
engraved on the back of the watch I
believe that the back of this watch I
actually had engraved with facts don't
care about your feelings that's correct
Oh check that out so that can be you as
well so go check them out right now at
VIN Cheryl watches comm /up here on you
Shapiro as your promo code a check out
to get a great deal all righty in just a
second we can get back to the Democrats
blaming Trump for the outbreak of
coronavirus which is just I'm sorry
that's crazy on every level we'll get to
that in a second first let's talk for a
second about my friend Matt Walsh Matt
Walsh is one of our hosts here at the
Daily wire he has a brand new book out
it is called Church of cowards a wake-up
call to complacent Christians Christians
and other countries are still being
martyred for their faith how many
American Christians are even willing to
put down their smartphones for their
faith Walsh breaks down the problem
found in modern American Christianity
this thing is surging up the charts so
go check it out right now pick it up at
Amazon or Barnes & Noble today the book
is called Church of cowards by my friend
Matt Walsh also if you haven't yet
jumped on a daily wire party bus a
reader's pass is a great way to dip your
toe into the community if you're
obsessed with news a readers pass will
enable you to read our articles ad free
including my op-eds which are exclusive
for daily wire Members Only you also get
access to our mobile app to read our
stories and receive push notifications
for breaking news and special content
perfect for when you want to stay up to
date on the go this membership tier is
already a bargain at 3 bucks a month if
you are still hesitant you should check
out our special offer right now we are
offering one month for 99 cents that is
mobile ad free access to all of
daily wire News exclusive op-eds from
yours truly and breaking news and
updates on our mobile app all for the
low low price of 1 buck give it a shot I
think you will be hooked by the way next
Tuesday March 3rd join me God King
Jeremy boring Andrew Clavin to Michael
Mills on daily wire backstage
we're gonna watch those results from
Super Tuesday roll in and in and in and
in all night long we'll have a cavalcade
of stars who will be stopping by to join
us should be a lot of fun to stop by for
that you're listening to the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so Democrats super super super eager to
blame President Trump for coronavirus
they're very upset because Trump
appointed his vice president Mike Pence
to lead up the coronavirus task force
here was Mike Pence yesterday paying
tribute to President Trump as only Mike
Pence can do but Democrats are going
nuts over all of this
Trump's made clear from the first days
of this administration we have no higher
priority than the safety security health
and well-being of the American people
and from the first word of a outbreak of
the corona virus the president took
unprecedented steps to protect the
American people from the spread of this
disease you counted those briefly but
the establishment of travel restrictions
aggressive quarantine effort of
Americans that are returning the
declaration of a public health emergency
and establishing the White House Corona
task force are all reflective of the
urgency that the president has brought
to a whole-of-government approach okay
so you know people are very angry at
pens because he's saying nice things
about Trump which is literally his job
description right he's the vice
president when was the last time Biden
said something bad about Obama it just
doesn't happen but people are going nuts
because like Pence is a science denier a
science tonight he's not denying
coronavirus exist nor is he holding up
the the necessity for measures that have
to be taken the Trump administration is
already going to Congress for additional
funding and they should receive that
additional funding this one is
bipartisan and easy guys you provide the
resources that are necessary in order to
fight the possibility of an outbreak but
the media are already blaming Trump for
a thing that hasn't happened yet this is
an insane piece by Gail Collins I mean
totally and utterly nuts Gail Collins
over at the New York Times so let's just
be straight about this you have a virus
a corona virus that has popped up coming
in 19 that has popped up in China on the
basis of a wild animal market people
eaten freaking bats and weird animals
nobody's ever heard of before and then
they get a virus they spread it
throughout this particular area the
Chinese government shuts down all
information the virus goes wild it goes
wild in that area then it is spread
across the globe to countries all over
the globe I mean just in the show I've
mentioned Israel Italy Germany Brazil
Japan
South Korea right everywhere I mean it
is now gone to every single populated
continent on planet earth every cop
populated continent on planet Earth has
been hit with coronavirus at this point
and the new york times is take from Gail
Collins is I'm not kidding this is their
headline let's call it Trump virus Trump
virus we don't have one confirmed death
in the United States from coronavirus
yet we have 3,000 in China we have a
bevy in various other areas of the world
we are still in double digits as far as
the number of people we know actually
have grown virus in the United States
and we have one count them one confirmed
case of somebody with a community
infection in the United States and Gail
Collins wants to call this Trump virus
I'm fairly certain that the Trump virus
has infected her brain and now like
syphilis it's corkscrewing through the
soft tissues I mean this is wild the
sub-headline is if you're feeling awful
you know who to blame really so you end
up with corona virus and your first
thought is Trump try it's not damn I
wish the Chinese government won't run
such a corrupt awful authoritarian evil
place your first thought is Trump okay
something wrong with Gail Collins I know
what happened to her I don't know if she
was dropped on her head as a baby or
what but here is her idiotic piece again
this is printed in the New York Times
the paper of record
so our coronavirus SAR is going to be
Mike Pence feeling more secure I know
full well the importance of presidential
leadership the VP said as soon as he was
introduced in his new role totally
qualified first criteria for every job
in this administration his capacity for
praising the gloriousness of our
commander-in-chief yeah when you think
of Mike Pence you maybe don't think
about pandemic fighters supreme but as
president from pointed out repeatedly he
has already run Indiana well it could
have been worse having a czar does make
you feel there's somebody in charge at
least Trump didn't come before the
cameras and announce solemnly today I'm
asking every American to cross your
fingers like what is this piece this
piece is basically I don't like Trump
and I don't like pence and therefore if
I get coronavirus it's their fault okay
I don't like Bernie Sanders but if I get
coronavirus it ain't Bernie's fault I
praise the schmuck but he has nothing to
do with the transmission of coronavirus
our president had to be going crazy over
a problem that involves both declining
stock prices and germs
this is the guy after all says Gail
Collins who thinks shaking hands is
barbaric
who's followed around by aides bearing
sanitizer during his press conference he
told the story of a fever ridden
supporter who gave him a hug do you
think it was in a
for fantasy either way the idea has been
haunting him forever so let me just get
this straight
you're so paranoid about coronavirus
you're not blaming it on Trump but
saying that Trump uses hand sanitizer
after shaking a thousand hands he's
paranoid okay like let me little secret
to people who don't shake a thousand
hands at events I've done it before you
know what you do afterward you go wash
your hands because you're an idiot if
you don't go wash your hands after you
shake a thousand hands the chances are
very good that somebody had a cold I get
come on meanwhile according to Gayle
Collins Trump has come up with a totally
new explanation for the stock market's
kid it turns out investors were
frightened not so much by the pandemic
as the democratic debate and then Trump
pointed out that people are frightened
by the Democratic candidates and Trump
said that he had discovered that the flu
in our country kills 25,000 people into
69 thousand people a year so the
problems are Democrats and the flu again
like I don't like that the president
doesn't know how many people died from
the flu every year but that does not
mean that he's not deploying the
resources that are necessary by the way
this was not even the dumbest response
okay the dumbest response came courtesy
of genius with the plan Elizabeth Warren
so senator Warren stumping for president
in a quixotic campaign to be Bernie
Sanders a second which is really what's
going on here she she did a CNN Town
Hall last night and she was asked about
coronavirus her response is so all-fired
moronic it is almost difficult to
describe how stupid this isn't this was
cheered because people are idiots here
is Elizabeth Warren I'm glad to see that
she's broken into the into the primary
color section of the Ann Taylor Loft
sweater closet so the so here is here's
Elizabeth Warren explaining that she is
going to redirect money from border
control to coronavirus here is Elizabeth
Warren's plan for dealing with
coronavirus the way I think about this
is first we think about allocation kind
of our overall approach I'm gonna be
introducing a plan tomorrow to take
every dime that the president is now
spending on his racist wall at our
southern border and divert it to work on
the coronavirus
we also need someone in the White House
who is coordinating all of the work and
all of the messaging and all of the
information and we need someone who is
not actively disqualified from doing
that the way the Vice President is why
is Mike Pence actively disqualified from
doing that she kind of failed to explain
that point other than she doesn't like
Mike Pence and hid and he needs a new
haircut like that that's pretty much her
only case I do love that she like just
just to boil this down she is going to
shut down Trump's racist border wall by
the way walls are inanimate objects so
it's it's weird that it's racist like
inanimate objects typically don't have
personality that way but she says that
Trump's race is sport we're gonna shut
down the border wall - flips through
card checks card stop global pandemics
so your answer to pandemics where the
problem is people transmitting a virus
through personal travel and crossing
borders your solution is less border
security so the American government
spends four trillion dollars a year it
seems to me there are a few grab bags of
cash in there somewhere that we could
use in an emergency plus we do sell an
awful lot of bonds here in the United
States in fact bond yields hurt an
all-time highs so taking out additional
debt is probably not gonna be a problem
at this point but the the bond yields
hurt an all-time low rather the demand
is at an all-time high they went when
Elizabeth Warren says that her solution
is to raid the border fund you know like
just on principle I understand the walls
not going to be built for a little while
but on principle if your first move is
I'm gonna go open the border to stop a
pandemic you are a full-scale idiot stop
a full-stop period you're a if
your solution - we have too much
transmissibility of viruses because of
human travel if your solution is get rid
of the border wall it's because you're
an idiot because you love the people
clapping like seals yeah cuz I hate
walls walls are bad also I'm gonna stay
home and I'm never gonna go into a
public place again cuz I'm scared of
coronavirus but yeah walls are super bad
super how do we know how stupid this is
New York Times today Mateen Aceves grin
Neff writing coronavirus net-net
nightmare could be the end of europe's
borderless dream oh you don't say it
turns out that people
borders without being checked could
spread disease you know who's been
making that case for a long time border
hogs many many border hawks reporting
from Brussels for Europe the corona
virus could not have arrived at a worse
time this was the year with Britain out
terrorism waning and the migrant crisis
had an ebb that the EU had hoped to
repair and revive its cherished goal of
open internal borders but cases of the
virus have emerged nearly daily in new
European countries Spain Greece Croatia
France Switzerland and on Wednesday in
Germany many of them can be traced back
to Europe's largest outbreak in Italy
where more than 300 people are now
infected as the cases spread and
multiply calls for closing borders have
grown louder most predictably from the
far-right and populist who were never
fans of the bloc's
open border policy so far no country has
taken that drastic step but privately
European officials warned this could
change quickly
on Wednesday the bloc's top official for
communicable diseases said that Europe
needed to prepare more broadly for the
kind of crisis that is hit northern
Italy the official Andrea M and director
of the European Centre for disease
prevention and Control says our current
assessment is that we will likely see a
similar situation in other countries in
Europe we also need to consider the need
to prepare for other scenarios for
example large clusters elsewhere in
Europe but that doesn't mean people
aren't talking about shutting borders
some people like dr. Clare Wenham of the
London School of Economics Global Health
Initiative she says travel restrictions
don't work people find another way
around it might only slow the virus down
well I mean slowing viruses down is good
thing
last I checked but it is amusing to
watch as the New York Times begins to
recognize that open borders have costs
meanwhile Elizabeth Warren's like let's
open that border solution to pandemics
open that border open that border so
Democrats keep trying to blame front for
coronavirus Trump's reaction should be
measured which of course is difficult
but he should he should react how he
reacted to Pelosi he's fine by the way
him saying to the Democrats you guys are
trying to make hay out of political out
of political out of a non political
tragedy is really disgusting and we
should all be on the same side on this
one we're all doing our best right that
is how Trump should be responding to
this end he should also be saying yes we
take it seriously yes we're doing
everything we can we don't know where
this is going yet but I promise you'll
be the first to know as soon as we get
information radical transparency all of
that would be useful the Democrats
however taking advantage of this by
claiming that Trump is responsible for
Trump virus this is because everyone is
a complete and utter fool okay meanwhile
we are approaching the South Carolina
primaries they're happening
on Saturday and believe it or not Joe
Biden could creep back into this race he
easily could creep back into this race
so there are a couple of new polls that
are out in South Carolina and they are
all showing Joe Biden up very very big
like not small big apparently there are
two new polls they show Biden up by
there's one from Monmouth today
it shows Joe Biden up by 20 points 20
points in South Carolina with Bernie
Sanders running even with Tom Steyer
which means that steyr could actually
finish ahead of Sanders there's also an
East Carolina University poll that came
out yesterday showing Biden up 8 over
Sanders and Sanders again running within
spitting distance of Tom Styer and a
Public Policy Polling it's a democratic
firm a polling firm that found Biden up
15 points in the Real Clear Politics
poll average Biden is up 14 points if
Biden wins by double digits this race
changes really dramatically it changes
really dramatically in a hurry because
the conventional wisdom and I will admit
I had helped by it was that as Joe Biden
had collapsed in the first states that
his black support would start to
collapse in South Carolina and you would
see Bernie pull out if not a victory
than a very narrow loss in South
Carolina but that doesn't appear to be
the way that the polls are going right
now and that means that Super Tuesday
all of a sudden looms very large bill
scher who is an analyst for real clear
news and Politico he put forward a
couple of different scenarios on the
math in one scenario he says Biden wins
40 to 25 in South Carolina over Bernie
and that translates to identical wins in
the south on Super Tuesday Alabama
Arkansas North Carolina Oklahoma
Tennessee Texas Virginia and Bernie
beats him badly in California Colorado
Maine Utah and Vermont he wins narrowly
in Massachusetts over Warren and he and
he basically splits with Klobuchar in
Minnesota in that scenario the Super
Tuesday plus out Carolina delegate count
looks like this Sanders 679 Biden 642 so
basically a dead heat after Super
Tuesday in that case let's say that
Biden wins thirty twenty in South
Carolina and then duplicates that sort
of response in a variety of other states
in the south
still if Warren ends up picking up like
15% across these various states and ends
up with 285 delegates a that means that
Biden and more of Biden and Sanders end
up within spitting distance of one
another so that would be Biden staying
within reach now if this turns into a
at Ray Sanders versus Biden everything
changes everything changes radically
because the Democratic Party does not
want Bernie to be the nominee they don't
learn to be the nominee they are
recognizing more and more that burning
his nominee is absolutely disastrous I
mean really disastrous they they seem to
be taking the position that Donny
Deutsch took on MSNBC yesterday he said
there's no way that Sanders can beat
Trump like this is just not a thing
that's going to happen clip 17 everybody
gets up and talks about what an
existential threat Trump is and he is
it's a serious game time and these
candidates the candidates you mentioned
Bloomberg really have to kind of look in
the mirror and say do I want to be a
part of serving Bernie Sanders up who I
think has zero chance of beating Donald
Trump you know this is we are at a
moment in time imagine Trump for more
years imagine god forbid Bernie on the
ticket and they take the house it's over
also Democrats two super delegates are
looking at this and saying if this thing
ends up pretty close to dead even
we are not handing it to Bernie article
in The New York Times today Democratic
leaders willing to risk party damage to
stop Bernie Sanders House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi and Senator Chuck Schumer the
Minority Leader her constant warnings
from allies about congressional losses
in November if the party nominates
Bernie Sanders for president by the way
Michael Bloomberg has already said he is
pulling all of his money from Bernie if
Bernie is the nominee he will not give
one thin dime to Bernie Sanders Bernie
as the nominee he'll give money down
ballot but Bernie's gonna hurt people
down ballot officials in the national
and state parties are increasingly
anxious about splintered primaries on
Super Tuesday and beyond dozens of
interviews with Democratic establishment
leaders this week show they are not just
worried about Sanders candidacy but are
also willing to risk intra-party damage
to stop his nomination at the national
convention in July
if they get the chance since Sanders his
victory in Nevada The Times has
interviewed 93 party officials and found
overwhelming opposition to handing
Bernie the nomination if he arrives with
the most delegates but fell short of a
majority which could result in a
brokered convention Jim Himes Kent
Connecticut congressman and super
delegate he says we're way way way past
the date where party leaders can
determine an outcome here but I think
there's a vibrant conversation about
whether there is anything that can be
done
Sanders continues to insist that he can
win but most Democrats do not think he
can win most of them think he's gonna
drag them down on the ballot and again
if Biden comes back that may be enough
of a story for Democrats to rau
around Joe Biden now the big problem for
Joe Biden is that he hasn't done any
legwork in a lot of the Super Tuesday
states at the same time the New York
Times is reporting that Biden has not
actually spent any time in many of these
southern states he's expected to win
places like Arkansas Michael John great
chairman of the Democratic Party of
Arkansas says Arkansas was in my opinion
gonna be a default Biden state he hasn't
been here of all the campaign's the
least organized in Arkansas is by now
that may not make a difference maybe
none of these campaigns are spending an
awful lot of time in these states but
Biden's campaign has been lackluster his
organization has been lackluster he
thought he's just gonna cruise to the
nomination that obviously has not been
true the Biden campaign has been has
been lackluster in terms of the ground
game gilberto Hinojosa the Democratic
Party Chairman in Texas which is the
second biggest delegate prize on Super
Tuesday
he said Bernie has a ground game because
he has a ground game his whole campaign
his grassroots Bloomberg has defunded
ground game Elizabeth Warren has a
ground game he says I haven't seen
anything other than the events he's had
in Texas for Biden so Biden hasn't done
all the hard work necessary in order to
actually go get those delegates now
maybe that changes after Super Tuesday
maybe he gets an infusion of cash if he
if he somehow emerges alive from Super
Tuesday or if he blows everybody out in
South Carolina suffice to say the race
isn't quite over Biden does have a shot
but Biden has run a really lackluster
campaign it's a mess for the Democrats
it is an absolute mess for the Democrats
right now over at 538 they've got their
estimates on who is likely to win the
nomination they've got no majority and
now the largest chance a one in two
chance 50% chance that there is no
majority and you have an open convention
they've got Bernie at about a 40% shot
they've got Biden at about one in eight
shot at winning a majority of the
delegates which doesn't has to make the
delegate leaders right I mean it could
be the biden ends up as the delegate
leader and there's still no majority so
it's a mess South Carolina is looming
large guys Saturday is gonna make a big
big difference okay time for some things
I like and then some things that I hate
so things that I like today so I do like
I do like clarity I'm a fan of clarity
and it is incredible to me that louis
farrakhan who's been hobnob with by half
the Democratic establishment I mean
literally half the Democratic
establishment Bill Clinton is hobnob
with Liz Farrakhan Barack Obama used to
hobnob with Louis Farrakhan half half of
the members of the Congressional Black
Caucus of hobnob with Louis Farrakhan he
doesn't hide the ball does Louis
Farrakhan not only is he
vicious anti-semite he also happens to
be a terror supporter so here is Louis
Farrakhan yesterday calling Qasem
Soleimani a man responsible for the
death of hundreds of American soldiers
in Iraq his brother
this guy Lou's Farrakhan you can't even
get Linda Sarsour to denounce Louis
Farrakhan you can't get anybody like I'd
love to hear Ilhan Omar denounce Louis
Farrakhan you think she would do that
I'll bet Bernie wouldn't denounce Louis
Farrakhan seriously somebody should ask
Bernie proud Jew Bernie about either him
or his surrogates denouncing Louis
Farrakhan but here's Louis Farrakhan
just this week talking about how his
brother was Qasem Soleimani
the Trump cue my brother Qasem Soleimani
and you said if my brother is a
terrorist and you got the power to
define to find people you may not like
me so you might call me a terrorist
tomorrow to justify what the government
is planning to do to me in the Nation of
Islam I'm just inviting you oh yeah
honestly this guy is very open about
exactly who he is
and I very much look forward to the
media asking serious questions of Bernie
surrogates hahahahaha about what they
think of Louis Farrakhan imagine if
every Republican member of Congress were
hanging out with David Duke okay who's
Farrakhan is David Duke he is he's just
awful he's an awful awful human being
but I don't think that Bernie will be
asked about any of that sort of thing I
don't think any of his surrogates will
be asked about any of that sort of thing
by the way again it is amazing we keep
hearing from people in sort of the
Bernie camp that Bernie is in fact not
in actual socialist like this is the new
line the new line is that Bern now the
Democrats are very focused on
maintaining the bernie is not who bernie
is so Bernie's been pretty clear about
who he is right now he's trying to lie a
little bit now he tries to say that
socialist just means but I won't dump
Republic la vodka but that's that's
obviously not what Bernie means and
Bernie used to be a lot clearer about
the stuff back in his more honest mayor
of Burlington days this is back in the
1980s burden Bernie being asked if he's
a capitalist and him saying no I don't
know capitalism is terrible you a
capitalist no I'm not uncomfortable
so you don't believe in the profit
motive free enterprise if I have a
better mousetrap I make more money
here's something to be said for free
enterprise on a local level and the
competition but what we're happening in
our society is we don't live in a free
enterprise society you live in a
corporate capitalist society we're in
virtually every single industry you have
giant multi-billion dollar corporations
competing driving the small businessman
about so he's not in favor of any of
this stuff
he's on a local maybe we will let a few
local people you know compete to sell
the eggs but we're not going to pull out
national corporate like this is who he
is this is who he is he's not hiding the
ball okay but everybody else gonna try
to hide the ball for him al sharpton
who's another disgusting human being
again the fact that al Sharpton has been
allowed to trot around in the media I
mean the man has a show on MSNBC and
who's responsible and or at least
involved in not one but two race riots
in New York City over the course of his
career I don't know how many race riots
you've been involved in for me the
answer is none for Al Sharpton the
answer is - al Sharpton was comparing he
Wester day in South Carolina
he compared Bernie Sanders to Martin
Luther King because people opposed
Martin Luther King and also they opposed
Bernie Sanders and socialism they accuse
dr. King of being a communist they tried
to call socialist economies whatever you
decide to do
to separate us don't try to use the
socialist second burn he's like um I
call myself a socialist I don't
understand I'm the one saying that
what's going on the the retconning of
Bernie Sanders is really entertaining
it really is it's sort of like in the
rise of Skywalker the the Kennedy team
or JJ Abrams at least he decided that he
was going to retcon the last Jedi he's
just gonna make it that the last Jedi
never happened and then he was gonna
retcon the entire history of Star Wars
where Leia had actually been trained as
a Jedi spoiler alert and all of this
stuff right here ed Condit everybody's
retconning Burnie now so Bernie has a
very long history here a very long
history of being awful and now we're
retconning him he was never really a
socialist he was really a free-market
guy he never really supported dictators
he was really like just he was against
our authoritarianism he just like their
literacy programs guys Bernie Sanders
never attacks war here as her CNN's
Kirsten powers saying that Trump is
worth more Lee than Bernie because
bernie has never attacked war heroes
again this is a full-on retconning
here's CNN's Kirsten powers trying to
defend Bernie crazy I mean truly I
respect the idea that Bernie Sanders is
some mirror image of Donald Trump's in
terms of his lack of civility I mean
does Bernie Sanders attack war heroes
just Bernie Sanders attack the parents
of war heroes does Bernie Sanders 12
people on Twitter every single day and
make misogynist attacks against people
racist I mean it's just it's ridiculous
and we need to put this aside he doesn't
attach a nose does not attack war heroes
do you understand that
quote from 1970 to Bernie Sanders about
American soldiers American soldiers the
US military action in Vietnam was quote
almost as bad as what Hitler did almost
as bad as what Hitler did he also
suggested that everybody who is fighting
the Vietcong he said they were very very
poor people some of them don't have
shoes they eat rice when they can get it
they've been fighting for the freedom of
their country for 25 years and they can
hardly fight back but don't worry he has
never slandered American
war heroes ever he's never done that
except for declaring that basically
every American War action of the last
thirty years is a human rights violation
but other than that he's a perfect
moderate guys perfectly perfectly about
again the retconning
of Bernie Sanders is going on a pace
we'll see how successful it is I don't
think it's gonna be particularly
successful and I think it's one of the
reasons why Joe Biden has continued at
least in the last in the last little
while it's why Joe Biden has continued
to be a durable candidate at least in
South Carolina we'll see if the carries
for it okay time for a quick thing that
I hate you remember there was this
really wonderful moment like the
everything good has to be ruined in
America that is the rule remember there
was this really wonderful moment maybe a
couple of years ago or Pete Davidson on
SNL he made a joke about my friend Dan
Crenshaw representative from Texas
congressman Crenshaw and Congressman
Crenshaw is a Navy SEAL who lost his eye
to an AED in Afghanistan Ben Crenshaw
made some sort of dismissive joke about
how Crenshaw looked like a pirate and
then he said well you know he probably
just I guess he you know got blown away
by an ie D or something right kind of
dismissive Lee suggested that and people
got very offended because it turns out
that when you insult the physical
appearance of people who have been
wounded in war that's not a particularly
popular viewpoint right that's kind of
an ugly thing to say no I don't think
Davidson should have lost his job or
been suspended over that he's a comedian
comedians say offensive things all the
time I believe I said this at the time
but that doesn't mean that the comment
wasn't gross I mean it was gross okay so
Crenshaw is so Davidson apologized and
he brought Crenshaw on and they had this
kind of wonderful moment on SNL where
Davidson talked about how I think it was
his father had died on 9/11 and Crenshaw
talked about how he had served after
9/11 and they had this sort of kumbaya
moment or Crenshaw went on he made fun
of Pete Davidson and everybody came away
thinking that Pete Davidson was a bigger
man than when he had started right that
was the take away the take away was Pete
Davidson realized he had said something
nasty and he took the hit and he did the
right thing and he invited Crenshaw on
and Crenshaw handled it with class and
Davidson handled it with class and
everybody felt pretty good about this
right left right and center you could
feel good about this because Crenshaw
had taken it like a like a man he had
taken the hit he'd treated it with good
humor he hadn't acted insulted or whiny
about it he just going on there made a
few jokes and then and then they'd
basically hugged it out and Davidson had
realized that he had said something
offensive and so he did what a
responsible person should do and he had
basically just eaten it they'd just
taken the hit and it was a manly thing
to do well now Pete Davidson being
apparently not a very manly sort of
fellow he's now coming back two years
later with the jerk Store response he's
very upset he says I never should have
made Jenn Crenshaw famous because it was
my fault
never should have made Crenshaw famous
never should have apologized just should
have owned it now is there a purpose to
this is there is there a purpose to this
the answer is there is no purpose to
this other than Davidson trying to buy
back his leftist bona fide ease right
its Davidson trying to now get back in
the good graces of a vicious left that
is fine with with making fun of war
heroes contractor Stan powers of CNN
here is Pete Davidson in his comedy
routine talking about how bad it was
that he that he made Dan Crenshaw famous
I said whatever and people like crime he
could have lost his eye in war or what
our army losses high could have been
Afghanistan gonna be making a sandwich I
have no idea I did not I did not do
anything for that guy the only thing I
did do which I am guilty of I apologize
for is I did make that guy famous and a
household name for no reason right I did
what like Ariana Grande bid for me right
yeah it's a funny line about him and
Ariana Ariana Grande but at the same
time the the line that he made crenshaw
famous for no reason and that he never
should have done any of this I
understand it's a comedy routine I'm not
gonna get offended by his comedy routine
his comedy routine is supposed to break
barriers and all this but I assume he
actually means this if he actually means
this and it's not just part of his
comedy routine buying it back then it's
pretty nasty thing to do right I mean
like again we had this nice bipartisan
can't we just have nice things like a
nice thing like a nice bipartisan moment
where you realize you made a mistake and
it was kind of offensive and then you
backed off it nobody thought the worst
of Pete Davidson I felt much better of
Pete Davidson in the aftermath and by
the way I didn't think the Pete Davidson
was like the worst guy in the world for
making the Dan Crenshaw joke in the
first place I thought it was just dumb
and I thought that it betrayed a certain
level of carelessness about how you
speak of people who are wounded in war
but at the same time like him now trying
to buy that back and say oh well I never
should have done that I made Crenshaw
famous just be nice just be nice like
especially because you've already done
it you don't you don't have to be nice
in the first place but once you've been
nice buying back the niceness it's not a
really great trait once you've done a
nice thing it's like you give your wife
a gift and then the next day and she's
really happy about it like you make a
mistake and you bring your wife flowers
and the next day for no reason at all
you're like you know what honey and you
just pick up the flowers and you trash
them
and I take that take I never should've
given you those flowers in the front
well now you know you've reopened this
thing now you've done it again dude
and maybe you need the controversy to
sell your comedy special or whatever but
wouldn't it be nice if we could just let
nice things be left alone and that thing
ended nicely and you bought it back it's
amazing
already well we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll be back here
tomorrow for more content for you by the
way next Tuesday March 3rd join me God
King Jeremy boring Andrew clay then
Michel moles on daily wire backstage
while we watch the results from Super
Tuesday Roland that means that my wife
needs to have a baby or something man
because we need to get that done before
Super Tuesday because that's gonna be a
busy day so go check us out March 3rd
Super Tuesday we will be having that
special daily wire backstage you'll be
virtually analyst so while I suffer with
my colleagues here you know I have to
suffer sitting in a room while they
while they perform performative
masculinity smoking cigars as they
prepare us for coronavirus you can at
least join us and be part of the show
we'll have a bunch of great guests go
check it out otherwise we will see you
here later today or tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Benton Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel white house key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike foramina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20/20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Kleber
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]